bonjour c'est frédéric taddeï vous
faites peut-être partie des gens ils
sont nombreux qui me demandent comment
faire pour l'émission de lundi prochain
alors c'est vrai que cette émission du
lundi 31 janvier est exceptionnelle elle
va commencer à 20h et elle va se
dérouler dans le cadre du festival nous
disent que sont rayés au théâtre du rond
point elle sera donc en direct du
théâtre du rond point il va y avoir pas
mal d'invités emmanuel todd marcel
gaucher céline spector claé guerre
françois bousquet nicolas framont cette
émission et en public vous pouvez donc
et assister au théâtre du rond point et
si vous ne pouvez pas vous rendre au
théâtre du rond point vous allez pouvoir
la regarder mais pas comme d'habitude
alors voici le mode d'emploi pour nous
suivre sur les réseaux sociaux soit vous
la regardez sur rtl sur rt france poids
tv slash il dit au rond-point oui je
sais ça fait idiot rond point mais bon
c'est quand même l'adresse elle et c'est
celle-là
sinon vous nous regardez sur youtube
youtube.com seul hrt france ou alors sur
facebook.com seul hrt france voilà donc
sur les réseaux sociaux ou alors
carrément vous venez au théâtre mais
enfin tout le monde n'habite pas paris
[Musique]